Ouais.
Un quantum circuit va être l'unité de valeur
pour ton activité — le qubit est l'unité d'information,
mais un circuit est l'unité de calcul.
Alors essayons de comprendre ce qu'est un quantum circuit
et regardons son anatomie.
Voilà à quoi ressemble un quantum circuit —
il se compose de plusieurs éléments : les qubits
sont représentés par ces lignes horizontales. Ici, on représente
un circuit qui a quatre qubits, comme tu peux le voir
ici. Les gates, maintenant —
c'est comme ça qu'on contrôle les qubits,
et on lit les gates de gauche à droite.
Les gates à qubit unique peuvent être des gates
à qubit unique ou des gates à plusieurs qubits.
Tu vois là le gate contrôlé —
c'est celui qui a la ligne entre deux des qubits,
et c'est là que l'opération d'intrication va se produire.
Et enfin, tu as la mesure et la sortie classique.
Et ce qui est très important : tu exécutes un circuit plusieurs fois
pour obtenir le résultat — c'est la notion de shots.
Un compteur de shots, c'est donc le nombre de fois
où tu dois répéter un calcul pour obtenir le résultat.
Bon —
à quoi ça ressemble ?
Regardons à quoi ressemble un circuit à deux bits —
c'est l'image que j'ai montrée avant, avec un changement de phase.
Et j'ai montré avant une opération qui effectuait cette rotation
qui permet de réaliser cette opération d'interférence.
Faisons donc une comparaison entre un circuit classique
et un quantum circuit. Dans un circuit classique, ce que tu
vas constater, c'est que tu ne vois pas de lunes bleues —
il n'y a pas de rotations, tout ici est rose.
Tu as les états uniques,
que ces gates laissaient voir auparavant.
Mais remarque le contraste que ça va offrir
quand on implémente vraiment un quantum circuit.
Ce sont les véritables circuits qu'on exécute sur nos ordinateurs quantiques,
et que toi aussi tu peux essayer.
Les circuits qu'on va créer
par la combinaison des gates
génèrent l'amplitude complexe complète —
l'image que je t'ai partagée
tout à l'heure. Pourquoi c'est important ?
Parce qu'on peut maintenant générer ces relations complexes
entre les qubits en termes de phases
et d'intrication, et ensuite, par l'acte de mesure,
on est capable de réduire cette quantité massive
de calcul qui se passe à l'intérieur en
une réponse importante.
Et c'est ainsi qu'on parvient finalement
à la réponse. Si on les place côte à côte, visuellement,
tu peux sentir qu'un circuit classique ne peut
jamais exploiter le vaste espace de calcul
qu'un quantum circuit peut exploiter.
C'est la meilleure façon de te donner cette intuition
de la richesse avec laquelle on peut accéder à ce grand espace d'états.
Et ce qui est beau là-dedans, c'est qu'on peut
avoir plusieurs classes de circuits pour
remplir des fonctions différentes. Alors,
par exemple, voici un circuit
conçu pour modéliser le risque financier.
Voici un exemple de circuit
utilisé pour la recherche et l'optimisation.
Et voici un exemple de circuit utilisé pour
simuler une molécule. Ce qu'il faut retenir, c'est
que tu peux concevoir différents circuits
pour différentes applications.
Les circuits qu'on conçoit sont ensuite capturés
dans un logiciel et conservés sous forme logicielle.
Dans notre cas, on les conserve dans Qiskit,
notre kit de développement open source pour le calcul quantique.
C'est l'un des frameworks logiciels
les plus utilisés pour le calcul quantique.
Et tu peux imaginer construire
des bibliothèques de circuits qui s'intègrent dans
des programmes classiques qui combinent maintenant le meilleur de la programmation classique
et le meilleur de la puissance quantique.